>> Juan: FORMER PROFESSIONAL
WRESTLER TURNED ACTOR JOHN CENA
ACCUSED OF MAKING A GROVELING,
PATHETIC APOLOGY TO CHINA.
PROMOTING HIS NEW MOVIE
"FAST & FURIOUS NINE" TO
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS WHEN HE
REFERRED TO TAIWAN AS BEING "THE
FIRST COUNTRY TO WATCH THE
FILM," THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
WAS NOT HAPPY WITH THAT
REFERENCE TO TAIWAN AS AN
INDEPENDENT COUNTRY SO HE
QUICKLY APOLOGIZED IN MANDARIN.
>> [SPEAKING MANDARIN]
>> Juan: HE SAYS HE'S SORRY
ABOUT HIS MISTAKE AND THAT HE
LOVES AND RESPECTS CHINA.
DID A WRESTLING STAR JUST GET
BODY SLAMMED BY CHINA?
>> Greg: I THINK WHAT HE DID
WAS COWARDLY AND DESPICABLE AND
IF I EVER SEE HIM FACE-TO-FACE I
WILL BE SURE TO TELL HIM THE
EXACT OPPOSITE, I HAD NO IDEA
THERE WERE NINE FAST AND FURIOUS
IS.
I THINK I MIGHT BE IN ONE OF
THEM IF THERE ARE THAT MANY.
IT JUST SHOWS YOU HOW EMBEDDED
OUR CORPORATE OVERLORDS ARE WITH
THE TOTALITY IT TOTALITARIAN
REGIME TO GET ARGUABLY THE
TOUGHEST ACTOR IN HOLLYWOOD TO
OFFER A GROVELING APOLOGY IN
MANDARIN.
I DON'T SEE CENA RUNNING AROUND
CRAPPING ON AMERICA AND
APOLOGIZING TO CHINA LIKE
LeBRON JAMES.
>> Juan: IN THE UNITED STATES
WE HAVE A ONE CHINA POLICY SO
SHOULD WE CHANGE AND SAY, YOU
KNOW, TAIWAN, WE RESPECT YOUR
INDEPENDENCE AND SOVEREIGNTY?
B5 TAIWAN IS A COUNTRY,
HONG KONG USED TO BE A
SOVEREIGN, IT'S BEEN TAKEN OVER
BY THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY,
THE CHINESE, IS NOW ENGAGED IN
AGAINST AN ENTIRE MUSLIM
POPULATION AND WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR AMERICA IS THAT WE ARE
SCREWED BECAUSE THEY DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO TRY TO INFILTRATE
AMERICAN SOCIETY AND CULTURE,
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE WILLING TO
PUT THEIR PROFITS FROM A
COMMUNIST REGIME IN A COUNTRY
THAT TREATS PEOPLE VERY POORLY,
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE FREEDOM TO
ACCESS THE KIND OF INFORMATION
TO TELL THEM THAT TAIWAN IS AN
INDEPENDENT COUNTRY, AND IT
IMPACTS EVERY ASPECT OF AMERICAN
LIFE WHETHER IT'S THE THINGS
THAT WE BUY, WHETHER IT'S OUR
PHARMACEUTICALS COMING FROM
CHINA, ALL OF OUR PPE AND
HOLLYWOOD NOW WITH OUR CULTURE,
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE TO TRY OR
FIRE A SHOT, THEY'VE ALREADY
INFILTRATED EVERY ASPECT OF
AMERICAN SOCIETY AND THAT DOES
NOT BODE WELL FOR THE FUTURE OF
OUR COUNTRY.
>> Juan: DANA, TO KATIE'S
POINT, IF THE FILM IS NOT SHOWN
IN CHINA, THE PRODUCERS AND THE
STARS WILL LOSE MILLIONS IF NOT
BILLIONS.
HOW WOULD YOU HANDLE THIS?
>> Dana: I THINK THEY
SHOULD'VE THOUGHT OF THAT BEFORE
AND I THINK THIS IS PITIFUL AND
IT'S NOT ATTRACTIVE, LET ME TELL
YOU.
I DON'T FIND THAT ATTRACTIVE AT
ALL, AND WHEN HE'S BASICALLY
DOING IS GROVELING AND PEOPLE
SAYING THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND,
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE CHINESE
THEN DO WITH A VIDEO LIKE THAT?
THEY USE IT AS ABSOLUTE
PROPAGANDA AND IT IS NOT RIGHT.
HOW MUCH MORE MONEY DO YOU NEED?
BE BOLD, STAND UP, TAIWAN
DESERVES OUR RESPECT AND OUR
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THEM.
LET ME TELL YOU ANOTHER THING,
DO YOU REMEMBER IN 2016 RIGHT
AFTER THE ELECTION, WHO WAS THE
FIRST HEAD OF STATE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO CALL?
HE CALLED TAIWAN.
THAT'S BOLD.
AND REMEMBER THAT IT WAS A HUGE
THING, MY GOSH, HOW CAN YOU
POSSIBLY DO THIS?
HE WAS SENDING A MESSAGE AND NOW
MAYBE HIS TEAM DIDN'T KNOW
EXACTLY, GOING BACK DECADES, THE
WAR ON POLICY ESTABLISHED IN
WASHINGTON, THE CHINESE HE
REALLY MAD.
HE DIDN'T CARE AND THAT I THINK
IS REALLY BOLD.
>> Juan: SO JESSE, THE MOVIE
IS GOING TO COME OUT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY PANDEMIC OVER, MOVIE
THEATERS ARE GOING TO BE FILLED
WHEN IT HITS THE U.S., ARE WE
GOING TO FORGET ABOUT THIS IN A
WEEK OR TWO AGO?
>> Jesse: WE WILL AND YOU KNOW
MY POLICY, I DON'T ATTACK PEOPLE
THAT CAN BEAT ME UP AND UP
POLICY IS WORKED OUT VERY
FAVORABLY SO I AM GOING TO SIGN
WITH CENA HERE, THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T EVEN
RECOGNIZE AN INDEPENDENT TAIWAN
SO WE EXPECT HIM TO?
AS ONE CHINA POLICY HAS BEEN
POLICY IN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT,
BOTH SIDES SINCE '79.
WE JUST SOLD THESE GUYS
DEFENSIVE WEAPONS TO KEEP THE
PEACE SO IF I'M GETTING PAID
$10 MILLION BY THIS FRANCHISE
AND THEY OPENED IN A CHINA
BOX OFFICE LAST WEEK AND FOR
$140 MILLION AND I MAKE A LITTLE
GAFFE ABOUT AN ISLAND THAT THEY
ARE PRICKLY ABOUT, I'M GOING TO
SAY HEY, MY BAD, I'M SORRY.
IT'S GOOD BUSINESS AND ITS GOOD
MANNERS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY --
>> Dana: HOW CAN YOU POSSIBLY
SAY THAT AND ALSO SAVE THE
WORLD?
THE TWO WORLD SAVED.
YOU'LL FIGURE IT OUT WHEN YOU
READ IT.
BUT THIS ISN'T ABOUT HUMAN
RIGHTS, THIS IS ABOUT THE
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY OF THE
COUNTRY, IT'S NUANCED AND I CAN
DO NUANCE.
AND I'M SIDIN